mit Leichengeruch hat die Hamas den
Nahen Osten überzogen das wahllose Töten
unschuldiger am vergangenen Wochenende
hat eine bislang nicht gekannte
Dimension erreicht Opfer dieses Terrors
ist letztendlich auch die Bevölkerung im
Gazastreifen die von der Hamas schamlos
dem ausgeliefert wird als sogenannte
menschliche Schutzschilde Schutzschilde
für Massenmörder wie wird Israel
reagieren die hamasführung soll
ausgelöscht werden wie reagieren dann
Iran und Hisbollah und welche
Verantwortung trägt die Regierung
Netanyahu für das Geschehen viele Fragen
in der
phönixrunde Angriff auf israel droht ein
Flächenbrand
[Musik]
phönixrunde herzlich Willkommen bei uns
meine Gäste gter konnemann ist bei uns
CDU Politikerin und sie sind
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
deutsch-israelischen
Parlamentariergruppe im Bundestag stimmt
Andreas Reineke ehemaliger Diplomat sie
waren Leiter des
Verbindungsbüros in ramala also quasi
Botschafter bei der palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde ebenso EU
sondergesander für den Friedensprozess
im nen Osten jetzt sind sie Direktor des
een Instituts Gido Steinberg ist
Islamwissenschaftler und Experte für den
Nahen Osten bei der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik und Sonne ist
bei uns Journalist Autor ehemaliger ARD
Korrespondent gerade zurückgekommen aus
Israel und wir verschweigen auch nicht
dass sie eh der erste Moderator dieser
Gesprächssendung waren Herr reinike
Israel ist seit seiner Gründung vor 75
Jahren ein Land im permanenten außen
Alarmzustand oder Ausnahmezustand
trotzdem ist das Land jetzt kalt
erwischt worden was ist da
passiert ja man hat wohl militärisch
nicht
aufgepasst das ist die erste Analyse die
auch nicht schwierig ist festzustellen
man ist aber wohl auch leichtsinnig
gewesen denn im Grunde genommen hätte
man erkennen können dass sich etwas
zusammenbraute die palästinensische
Bevölkerung war frustriert über ihre
eigene Regierung die die sie nicht
vertreten hat und ihn nicht geholfen hat
sie war frustriert über die mangelde
Perspektive für das Land selber
wachsende Siedlungsbau siedlergewalt und
man merkte ja schon an den Anschlägen in
den letzten Monaten und Jahren dass da
irgendetwas im Gange war dass das jetzt
nun so war und dass die Israelis das
nicht falsch eingeschätzt haben ist
natürlich eine ganz besondere trage
gewesen sie waren ja am Samstag noch in
Israel gewesen als es diesen
unbeschreiblichen Terrorakt gab jetzt
werden schon historische Vergleiche wie
die zweite
intifata auch mit dem ägyptischsyrischen
angriffskskrieg vor 50 Jahren wo sie als
junger Reporter mit dabei waren zum JOM
kipur Tag
1973 hat dieser Vergleich wird gezogen
man spricht sogar von dem heftigsten
Angriff auf jüdisches Leben sei der CH
der
Naziverbrechen gegen die Juden was
erleben wir hier gerade
als am Samstag morgen um 6:30 Uhr die
Sirenen in telaviv gingen und dann ein
Freund ein israelischer militäranalst
anrief und mich warnte und sagte das ist
ein Ernstfall war mir sofort klar die
Geschichte wiederholt sich vor 50 Jahren
ist Israel blind in diesen Krieg
hineinestolpert und das ist diesmal ganz
genauso fast noch schlimmer und es waren
ja nicht nur die Militärs es waren ja
vor allem die Geheimdienste der shinbet
israelische imdienst hat ja jede Menge
menschliche Quellen in Gaza seit vielen
Jahren und dass man das alles übersehen
hat das ist unverzeilich und
unerklärbar Joe Biden dazug gegeben
dasselbst die amerikanischen
Geheimdienste da offenbar nicht im Bilde
waren Herr Steinberg das Bild vom
Pulverfass nah Osten das ist ja nicht
neu aber ist das jetzt genau der Funke
der Funke vor dem wir uns immer
gefürchtet haben das ist auf jeden Fall
gut möglich im Moment sieht es so aus
als
könnte der könnte der Krieg auf den
gaserstreifen beschränkt werden aber die
Gefahr ist groß dass er sich ausweitet
die Hamas zumindest rechnet damit der
Hamas Militärchef hat das am Samstag
ganz klar gemacht er hat die Verbündeten
im islamischen Widerstand wie er das
selbst formuliert hat in der Region
aufgerufen doch bitte mitzumachen und er
hat die Länder und Kräfte auch direkt
genannt Iran Libanon Irak Syrien und und
Jemen es wird sicherlich für die
Israelis die USA und auch andere Akteure
darum gehen diese Eskalation zu
vermeiden das wird schwierig genug wenn
dieser Krieg wie zu erwarten ist dann
doch etwas länger dauert Frau kemann
welche handfesten auch materielle
Unterstützung welche handfeste auch
materielle Unterstützung muss
Deutschland jetzt Israel geben über die
verbalen Solidaritätsbekundungen
hinaus tatsäch iche Solidarität die sich
dann in Handlung festmacht der
Botschafter Israels war in unserer
Fraktion zu Gast am Dienstag und wurde
gefragt was erwarten sie von Deutschland
da sagte dass Deutschland an unserer
Seite steht auch über diesen Tag hinaus
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten und
zwar außenpolitisch innerhalb der EU in
der UN aber dann eben auch innerhalb
Deutschlands denn wir sehen ja durchaus
dass ein kleiner Flächenbrand inzwischen
auch schon in Deutschland angekommen ist
und wir uns als wehrhafter Staat auch
geben bis hin zu der Tatsache zu sagen
wir stoppen jetzt die Zahlung auch an äh
äh äh gegebenenfalls
Terrororganisation
Vorfeldorganisationen wir prüfen diese
Zahlungen ähm wir sehen aber auch dass
wir jüdisches Leben in Deutschland
wirklich schützen und zwar wirklich
schützen was mich wirklich umtreibt ist
die Tatsache
dass heute der jüdische Sportverein
makabi sagt wir stellen den Spielbetrieb
ab weil wir um unsere Sicherheit
fürchten
dass wirklich auch Flächen weit hier
Hakenkreuze kill the Jud auf die Mauern
geschmiert werden und dem Grunde nach
auch wieder Flaggen
zerrissen verschmutzt oder
aber verbotene Demonstration nicht
eingestellt werden können und das heißt
der Staat muss deutlich wehrhafter
werden als er zur Zeit ist um dieses
jüdische Leben zu schützen auch vor dem
Hintergrund dass Hamas für Freitag
angekündigt hat jüdisches Leben in der
ganzen Welt zu attackieren denn am Ende
will Hamas nicht nur israelische Juden
töten sondern alle Juden auf der Welt
das ist Teil des der Überzeugung der
Hamas Isel ist es ja auch nach 5 Tagen
noch nicht gelungen den Angriff der
Hamas endgültig zurückzuschlagen es wird
vermutet dass immer noch Hamas
Terroristen in Israel im Süden in der
Negev unterwegs sind was sind das
eigentlich für Gegner die Israel da hat
was sind das für Leute diese Hamas
Terroristen die wir ja in
selbstgedrietenen Videos am Samstag da
über den stacheldrahzaun haben steigen
sehen die sind stark und sie sind
stärker als die Israelis sich das
vorgestellt haben und das ist glaube ich
einer der Fehler den sie den sie gemacht
haben die politische Führung und die
militärische Führung sind mit einer
gewissen Arroganz an das Thema
Gazastreifen herangegangen das hat man
in den letzten Monaten ganz gut
beobachten können es ging immer um Iran
es ging immer um die Hisbollah und es
ging nie um die Hamas und die Hamas die
wird jetzt seit mittlerweile 30 Jahren
vom Iran und von der Hisbollah
unterstützt ähm nicht nur nicht nur mit
Geld nicht nur mit Waffen und Raketen
vor allem mit Ausbildung
ähm und das hat ganz genau im Jahr 1993
begonnen die erste Folge waren
Selbstmordattentate eine spätere Folge
waren dann die Raketen und eine ganz
späte Folge ist dieser doch sehr
professionell geführte Angriff den
glaube ich viele israelische
Militärplaner der Hamas in dieser Form
nicht
zugetraut haben die Hamas ist trotzdem
ein pragmatischer Akteur die haben ganz
klare Ziele sie wollen Israel zerstören
sie wollen einen islamischen Staat in
den Grenzen des mandatsgebiets Palästina
errichten und dort natürlich die Macht
übernehmen und sie arbeiten an diesem
Ziel sie arbeiten dann daran vor allem
indem sie nicht nur kämpfen sondern auch
Bündnisse schmieden und über die über
die Jahre hinweg sich in diese große
Achse des Widerstandes eingegliedert
haben wie die Iraner sie gerne nennen
also die wichtigsten Verbündeten sind
die Islamische Republik die Hisbollah
schiitische Milizen im Irak in Syrien
und im jeemen und dieses Bündnis das
müssen wir uns auch klar machen ist in
den letzten Jahren enorm erstarkt und es
ist eine Folge der letzten 10 Jahre
Unruhen im Nahen Osten dass auch die
Hamas davon profitier das nennt sich ja
ganz folkloristisch auch noch obwohl es
brandgefährlich istis schiidischer
Halbmond vom Iran bis ans Mittelmeer
interessant heranike ist ja was wir oder
was viele am Samstag auch staunt hat
dass das KfT das militärische
Kräfteverhältnis zwischen der
israelischen Armee hochgerüstet mit
amerikanischen mit modernsten afri
amerikanischen Waffen auch
wahrscheinlich mit Atomwaffen
ausgerüstet auf der anderen Seite
Kämpfer die in einer ja Enklave
festsitzen die man leicht kontrollieren
blockieren kann
und trotzdem sind sie mit diesem Angriff
nicht richtig fertig geworden am Anfang
ist das ja ist eine neue Qualität eines
einesri muss man sagen es ist ja eine
Mischung aus Krieg und gerill Krieg der
besonders schwer auszumachen ist es eben
nicht wie beim jomkipur Krieg wo man
eine Armee hatte die kamen sondern es
sind Leute die über den Zaun kletterten
mit paragleiders selbstgebauten
paragleiders kamen zum Teil aber auch
mit modernen Waffen das darf man auch
nicht vergessen es gibt ja auch
amerikanische Waffen dort und man
vermutet oder einige vermuten dass die
vielleicht aus Afghanistan bis dorthin
gelangt sind ist auch egal jedenfalls wo
sie herkommen auf jeden Fall sind sie
viel besser ausgerüstet gewesen als man
gemein den gesehen hat man hat aber auch
schon vorher in der zweiten intifana
gesehen selbst in der ersten
Ende der 80er Jahre die aber noch ohne
Waffen ausgeführt wurde dass es wie
schwierig es ist gegen gegen eine eine
eine Gruppe vorzugehen die aus der
Bevölkerung heraus äh agiert und dort
versucht Anschläge zu äh durchzuführen
also das ist eine große Herausforderung
wir vergessen nicht wir haben ja da
schätzen die Israel etwa 15 000 äh
bewaffnete
hamaskämpfer und es sind bisher in
Anführungszeichen nur 1500 auf
israelischem Gebiet gewesen die übrigens
alle gestorben sind und man kann davon
ausgehen dass sie auch wussten auf was
sie sich einließen also ist fast eine
Art Selbstmordkommando gewesen was ja
nicht unüblich ist nein aber dieser
Komplexität schon also das in dieser
Größenordnung ist das schon was ganz
besonderes und man kann also nur erahnen
dass die anderen
13500 ja auch noch irgendwo sind und
wenn Israel jetzt dort hineingeht wird
das ein ganz ganz schwerer Kampf werden
Sonne welche Rolle spielt denn die
derzeitige innenpolitische Situation wir
haben ja gerade von Guido Steinberg
gehört eine gewisse Arroganz war da
vielleicht eine Überheblichkeit der
falsche
Selbstsicherheit israel hat ja eine
schwere innenpolitische Krise
durchgemacht Stichwort Spaltung des
Landes Justizreform da wollte eine
radikale religiöse Gruppierung in der
Koalition die Demokratie aus den Angeln
heben welche Auswirkung hat das gehabt
das hat ja heute ganz konkrete
Auswirkung gehabt Benjamin Netanjahu hat
ja seit vorgestern schon begonnen für
eine Regierung der nationalen Einheit zu
werben und heute am Abend ist die
tatsächlich umgesetzt worden äh das ist
das erste konkrete Ergebnis was die
Innenpolitik angeht es gibt ein neues
kriegskabinett in dem ja auch ein
früherer Verteidigungsminister ganz
vertreten ist
der führende
Oppositionelle jair Lapid leider nicht
der darauf bestanden hat dass die
Ultraorthodoxen ultraradikalen in der
Netanyahu Regierung erstmal Ausscheiden
müssten aber das spielt
keine wirkliche Rolle mehr denn die sind
eigentlich entmachtet wir haben jetzt
ein kleines kriegskabinett das fällt die
Entscheidungen und alles andere was da
innenpitisch
über Monate kontrovers diskutiert worden
ist ist erstmal auf Eis gelegt worden
und ich glaube dass je länger das alles
gehen wird die politische
innenpolitische Landkarte in Israel neu
gezeichnet werden wird ich glaube nicht
dass diese netanyaho Regierung nach dem
Krieg noch existieren wird ich habe das
ja vor 50 Jahren nach dem jomkipur Krieg
auch live sozusagen erlebt da wurde erst
einmal der Krieg beendet dann wurde er
aufgearbeitet und dann trat die
Regierung Golder Meir zurück unter dem
innenpolitischen Druck weil sie versagt
hatte so und da da da lege ich meine
Hand für ver das wird diesmal auch
passieren Frau kann sie haben ja Kontakt
zu israelischen Parlamentariern es geht
jetzt um diese wie gesagt diese
ultrareligiösen Gruppierungen die diese
Justizreform durchdrücken wollen die
sind auch stark vertreten in der
Siedlerbewegung die sich ja offenbar zum
Ziel gesetzt haben eine maximale
Demütigung der Palästinenser in den
besetzten Gebieten das hat ja wohl dazu
geführt wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe dass die Armee immer mehr Einheiten
ins westjordan dann schicken musste um
die Ordnung aufrecht zu halalten und die
auch vom Gazastreifen abgezogen also
gibt es da eine direkten kausalen
Zusammenhang mit dem was da letzten
donnerst letzten Samstag passiert ist
natürlich hat der Gegner und das ist
eben nicht nur Hamas sondern am Ende
eine Achse die ich auch übrigens
fortschreiben würde bis Moskau
über Syrien über
Libanon über Iran
ähm sehr wohl beobachtet das
innenpolitisch die Aufmerksamkeit nicht
mehr auf dem in Gaza gelegen hat und da
gab es ja vieles es gab vielleicht auch
das Gefühl oder bestimmt das Gefühl wir
hatten den Abram Accord auch das das so
ein Stückchen eine Beruhigung auch
eingetreten ist durch die durch die
neuen Verhandlung z.B mit Bahrain
beispielsweise
durch gleich kurz erklären Abraham akord
es sind die Verhandlungen
mit
Saudi-Arabien
Saudiarabien also mit bahin und fein
arabischen ähm das war im Prinzip so das
Geschenk das Trump hinterlassen hat wenn
man das so kurz zusammenfassen will und
das heißt es gab ein Stückchen auch ein
bisschen eine Art Frühlingsstimmung die
dazu führte dass man sich sehr stark auf
die Innenpolitik auch konzentriert hat
eigentlich eine Stückchen Normalisierung
die wir uns ja für für für viele Länder
auch wünschen dass man mehr auf die
Innenpolitik schaut als auf die
Außenpolitik aber für was kein Land
gewappnet sein kann ist dieses Massaker
das angerichtet worden ist denn es geht
nicht um einen kriegsangriff es geht
auch um keinen kampfangriff was passiert
ist ist ein Massaker wie es das seit der
Schoa nicht gegeben hat dass wie ein
progrom gewirkt hat denn dem Grunde nach
sind hier Kinder
Frauen alte Menschen abgeschlachtet
worden wie die SS Juden abgeschlachtet
hat und das ist der Vorgeschmack auf den
Genozid der tatsächlich mit der Hamas
auch drohen wird und weshalb die Hamas
zu stoppen ist Herr Sonne dieser Abram
akord also diese Aussöhnung oder diese
Verständigung mit Saudi-Arabien die
musste ja die Hamas als besondere
Bedrohung empfinden absolut ja also
davon
wenn man da genauer hinschaut wird man
sich natürlich die Frage stellen müssen
warum jetzt und
ich bin davon überzeugt es ging vor
allem darum diese intensive Annäherung
an die arabische Welt zu to Bieren und
vor allem die an
Saudi-Arabien das sollte ja in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen endgültig zu
einem positiven Ende kommen und
damit wären die Palästinenser noch
stärker an die Seite gerückt worden die
ohnehin gespürt haben dass durch die
Abrams accords also die bereits erfolgte
Annäherung den Friedensschluss mit den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten mit
anderen arabischen Staaten äh das dann
mit Saudi-Arabien dem wichtigsten
konservativen islamischen Staat der der
der Hüterin der des Islam schlecht hin
wenn das
dazu kommen würde
dass man dass auch Saudi-Arabien Frieden
mit den Juden macht dann wäre das ein
schwerer Schlag gegen die Palästinenser
und ich glaube dass das das
entscheidende Motiv war jetzt so in
dieser brutalen Weise zuzuschlagen mit
folgendem Ziel möglichst viele
palästinensische Tote zu schaffen die
palästinensische Bevölkerung in Gaza als
Geiseln zu nehmen wie das immer
geschehen ist in den letzten Jahren
durch die Hamas und dann durch diese
vielen Toten zu sagen seht her die
Israelis das sind die das sind die
schlechter
und so und möglichst die arabische
Straße zu mobilisieren gegen diesen
Friedensprozess ich glaube da das ist
das eigentliche Motiv warum es jetzt
dazu gekommen ist bevor wir auf diese
geostrategische Lage im nahenosten
schauen würde ich ger mal ein Schitt
zurückgehen Gazastreifen und den geht es
ja jetzt auch ein bekanntes Gebiet da
gab's schon viel Gewalt 40 km lang 6 bis
14 km breit Leben 2 Millionen Menschen
auf engstem Raum das ist ja glaube ich
relativ flach von der ein Seite wird von
mehr begrenzt läs lässt sich begrenzt
wird lässt sich ja eigentlich auch
ziemlich gut kontrollieren von allen
Seiten und trotzdem hat die Hamas im
Laufe der Jahre da eine unglaubliche inf
militärische Infrastruktur auch ein
Vernichtungspotenzial aufbauen können
wie wir jetzt sehen auch durch die glaub
30.000 Raketen die sie insgesamt haben
ähm war man da auch in der Beziehung auf
israelischer Seite zu nachlässig oder
haben da andere mitgeholfen dass die
Hamas sich nach wie vor da gut halten
kann na ja also ich bin ja häufig in
Gasa gewesen hab mir das Hal angeschaut
das ist also wirklich ein ein sehr enges
Viertel viele also quasi durchgehende
Bebauung ganz wenige ganz wenig
Landwirtschaft die dort ist und ist
natürlich ein Land wie Israel auch in
einem Dilemma natürlich könnte man sich
theoretisch vorstellen dass man das
vollständig kontrolliert das hieße aber
dann das Leben in dem Gazastreifen
letztendlich unmöglich zu machen denn
die Leute müssen rein raus man braucht
Versorgung die Leute wollen ja etwas
verkaufen also bisschen Landwirtschaft
gemacht also man muss in irgendwie ein
Leben ermöglichen und diesem Dilemma
steckte Israel übrigens auch die Ägypter
die ja Richtung äh Richtung äh Süden
dann auch äh dort die Kontrolle haben
also man konnte das gar nicht so
kontrollieren wie man sich das
militärisch vielleicht vorstellte dazu
kommt es ist Sandboden und in diesem
Sandboden hat die Hamas und übrigens
auch die anderen Palästinenser haben
dann Tunnel gebaut vor allen Dingen zu
einem Zeitpunkt nach Ende des nach Abzug
der Israelis in dem
in dem also diese jetzige Situation noch
gar nicht da war Umgang stiet und
einfach die Versorgung V gaserstreifen
zu ermöglichen und die sind inzwischen
ganz professionell aufgebaut worden und
das ist auch wieder ein Dilemma zum te
sind die betoniert deswegen haben die
Israelis gesagt wir wollen da kein kein
Beton reinbringen da sagten die
Palästinenser aber guck mal die Häuser
sind kaputt wir müssen da irgendwie
Häuser haben und es ist quasi nicht
kontrollierbar ob da nur 100 Sack Beton
reinkommen und da weiß man jetzt wie
viel gehen in den Tunnel wie viel gehen
woanders hin ahnungslos durchgewunken
worden na ja nicht ahnungslos aber was
wollen sie machen sie haben also es
zeigt im Grunde genommen dass die
Vorstellung ein solches Land zu
kontrollieren von außen unrealistisch
ist und es ist selbst militärisch
unrealistisch wie wir jetzt gesehen
haben und das ist eigentlich das große
Dilemma und die große Frage vor der wir
letztendlich stehen werden denn auch
wenn jetzt Israel Hamas vernichtet dann
stellt sich ja die Frage was kommt denn
danach eigentlich wer kontrolliert denn
den hammerstreifen den den Gazastreifen
Frage ist ja genau was kommt danach Herr
steinwack es gibt ja eine Gründungsakte
der Hamas aus dem Jahr
1988 da steht ja unter anderem drin
nicht nur dass der Staat Israel in
seiner Existenz vernichtet werden soll
sondern es ist quasi Pficht der Muslime
jede Jüdin jeden Juden den man irgendwo
trifft sofort umzubringen zu
massakrieren was ja jetzt auch geschehen
ist mit einer solchen Einstellung einer
solchen teuflischen Einstellung ist doch
eigentlich kaum denkbar dass jemals da
irgendwie etwas wie Verständigung
Ausgleich oder zumindestens eine
einigermaßen akzeptable Nachbarschaft
herrschen kann also eine eine
Verständigung mit der Hamas ist
natürlich nicht nicht möglich und das
ist auch keine keine neue Erkenntnis es
hat durchaus einige Beobachter gegeben
die mal der Meinung waren dass
vielleicht ein etwas längerer
Waffenstillstand möglich wäre das mag
jetzt mal dahingestellt sein ob das ob
das so realistisch war aber die Hamas
ist da ist da ganz ganz eindeutig es
geht um die Zerstörung des Staates
Israel und um die Errichtung eines
islamischen Staates auf diesem Boden und
da war die Hamas nie zu komom missen
bereit wir haben aber gerade ja noch
über den Gazastreifen geredet ich glaube
wir müssen noch über einen Punkt reden
die Israelis haben diesen Gazastreifen
ja nicht mehr besetzt sie haben die
Besatzung des Gazastreifens 2005
aufgegeben ihre Truppen zurückgezogen
auch ihre Siedlungen
abgebaut und sie wollten die Kontrolle
weiterhin wahrnehmen und aus meiner
Sicht war das ein ganz ganz
entscheidender Fehler weil sie das war
aber vor der Machtergreifung der Hamas
das war vor der das war vor der
Machtergreifung der Hamas es wurden
danach Wahlen organisiert die Hamas hat
die Wahlen gewonnen äh sie hat die Macht
übernommen und die natürlich nicht mehr
abgegeben und
da liegt der eigentliche Fehler die
Israelis haben dann geglaubt dass sie
wenn sie das Gebiet abriegeln und
das Gebiet isolieren von der Außenwelt
dass sie dann in der Regel in der Lage
sind
die Hamas trotzdem zu kontrollieren das
ist sehr lange gut gegangen ähm auch
wenn es Raketenangriffe gegeben hat aber
da zeigt sich eben dass das nicht nicht
möglich war und äh wenn man sich die
wenn man sich die Äußerungen
israelischer Politiker der letzten Tage
anhört dann ist doch ganz klar dass sie
diesen diesen Fehler von
200567 dass sie den in irgendeiner Weise
revidieren wollen sie scheinen noch
keine genaue Vorstellung davon zu haben
möglich dur bofensive die Bodenoffensive
wird es geben ich glaube dass es immer
noch offen ist wie genau die aussieht
für die gibt es ja unterschiedliche
Szenarien aber wenn man die Aussagen von
Benjamin Netanyahu aber auch des
Militärs ernst nimmt dann geht es darum
die Hamas jetzt von der Macht zu
entfernen m und nehmen wir einmal das an
das gelingt dann wird sich natürlich die
Frage stellen ist danach eine
Wiederbesetzung des Gazastreifens
geplant oder kommen vielleicht
internationale Friedenstruppen oder will
man vielleicht sogar die ganz ganz
schwache
Autonomiebehörde aus der Westbank wieder
in den Gazastreifen schicken aber in
jedem Fall werden wir es mit einer ganz
langen mit einem ganz langen Krieg zu
tun haben und großen Fragen die
wahrscheinlich erst erst danach anstehen
es wird unglaublich schwierig selbst
wenn der Gazastreifen eingenommen werden
kann den auch längerfristig zu
kontrollieren liegt den Abrahams accords
auf Eis es sind die
Verhandlungen mit Saudi-Arabien erstmal
Vergangenheit da das kann ich eigentlich
nur die Mulla sinteran freuen also es
liegt noch nicht auf Eis ich stimme
Ihnen zu dass
die Friedensverhandlungen mit
Saudi-Arabien der entscheidende Grund
waren den Angriff jetzt
zu schlagen der natürlich vorbereitet
war denn diese Art an Ausstattung
bekomme ich nicht von einem Tag auf den
anderen äh und auf jeden Fall auch
geplant eben in dieser Achse die wir
mehrfach angesprochen haben ähm die
Frage bleibt äh tatsächlich ähm wie
bringt sich auch dort die
Weltgemeinschaft ein wie bringt sich z.B
USA und Co ein äh und
welche Bilder entstehen und das das
Dilemma ist für Israel dass sie
barbarisch angegriffen werden aber
selbst alles daran setzen müssen keine
barbarischen Bilder zu erzeugen was
außerordentlich schwierig ist wenn Hamas
das tut was es immer getan hat in diesem
Fall sogar Geisel noch zu nehmen aber
auch seine eigene Bevölkerung als
Schutzschild einzusetzen
Kommandozentralen einzubauen in
Kindergärten und Schulen ähm das ist ein
teuflisches Spiel was die Hamas treibt
ähm weil sie am Ende ihre eigene
Bevölkerung nicht liebt ähm und ähm äh
außerordentlich schwierig für die
Israelis aber ich glaube dass das
Interesse ähm auch bei den Saudis am
Ende durchaus gegeben ist den was hätte
auch im Gaza entstehen können
ehrlicherweise man hätte im Gaza hätte
auch in Singapur des narosts entstehen
können die Chance ist nach wie vor
durchaus gegeben wenn man sieht dass das
Interesse auch der der anrener Staaten
ja durchaus gegeben ist ich sehe auch
Jordanien beispielsweise Ägypten aber es
ist außerordentlich schwierig und
deswegen ist es wichtig immer auch
wieder die Sachverhalte einzuordnen dass
z.B die Grenzübergänge nicht von den
Israelis gesprengt worden sind sondern
von der Hamas gesprengt worden ist dass
die Herausforderung jetzt darin besteht
wie kann ich noch einen humanitären
Transport von Lebensmitteln
beispielsweise sicherstellen wie kann
ich ein cororritor absichern wo dann
nicht eben auf der anderen Seite
Terroristen wiederkmen die die
israelische Bevölkerung belagern und das
geht am Ende auch nur im Spiel z.B mit
den USA denn ehrlicherweise
ähm die die Tatsache dass die USA
Flugzeugträger bereits positioniert hat
bzw schickt und die Mobilisierung der
300.000 Reservisten hat am Ende dazu
geführt die hisbolla die ja immer auch
noch im Hintergrund agiert ähm äh auf
Abstand ein Stückchen zu halten aber sie
ist sie ist da und äh unfassbar gut
ausgestattet und hat sehr deutlich
gesagt unsere Waffen und unsere Raketen
sind auch eure Waffen und eure
Raketen und von daher
es ist alles ungemein fragil und
deswegen ist am Ende auch die Welt
gefordert kommt jetzt darauf an W Sonne
wahrscheinlich wie hatt diese Kämpfe
werden aber ist das gesamte ist die
gesamte Verständigung die es schon gibt
zwischen Israel und Teilen der
arabischen Welt Marokko Ägypten vien
Vereinigte Arabische Emirate Oman ist
das auch gefährdet
gefährdet ist ein zu großes Wort äh wenn
man sich das genauer anschaut was z.B
heute passiert ist wir hatten einen
Gipfeltreffen der arabischen
Außenminister in Cairo und es fällt ja
auf dass dort nur gemäßigte Töne
angewandt wurden und keine Rede davon
war dass man sich jetzt
formal von Israel abwenden wird das ist
wenn man so will wenn man genau
hinschaut eine wichtige Botschaft die
heute aus Ciro gekommen ist und ich
glaube nicht dass dass ich vor allem
Saudi-Arabien von der Hamas vorschreiben
lassen wird ob sie weiter mit Israel
verhandeln werden oder nicht ich bisher
liegt das alles nicht auf Eis es kann
durchaus so kommen wir werden noch ein
paar Töne auch schärfere Töne aus der
arabischen Welt hören Lippenbekenntnisse
werden das zumeist sein aber ich glaube
nicht dass diese das dieser
Friedensprozess damit beendet werden
wird noch zur und Steinberg hat ja
natürlich das ganze Bedrohungsszenario
schon aufgeblättert die es gab heute
wieder ein ein paar Nadelstiche ich habe
eben mit der mit dem Sprecher der der
israelischen Streitkräfte kurz noch
telefoniert darüber ist auch ein ein
Soldat dabei umgekommen israel hat ja
auch schon reagiert aber bisher sind es
nur Nadelstiche und das muss nicht mal
die hisbolla gewesen sein es gibt ja
noch weiterhin große Flüchtlingslager
palästinensische im Libanon und und es
sieht eher danach aus dass diese
Palästinenser da versuchen eben Unruhe
zu schaffen und ich glaube wir können
heute Abend hier festhalten nur wenn
Teran auf den Knopf drückt wird die
hisbolla reagieren die wird nicht von
alleine losstagen wenn Teran sagt die Go
dann dann wird es allerdings einen
Flächenbrand aber die Frage wir wird
heran das machen die his ist ja von
einem wstensinn des Wortes ganz anderen
Kaliber als ja ich glaube man sollte
auch den Einfluss des Iran auf hisboll
nicht überschätzen ist ja auch eine
eigenständige Gruppierung man sieht wie
sie richtig geschildert haben dass sie
im Augenblick gar nicht besondes
Interesse haben sich in diesen Krieg
hineinziehen zu lassen es kann aber eine
Situation entstehen und das sind die
zwei Punkte die für uns glaube ich auch
politisch wichtig ist das durch die die
Bilder von von Blut und Toten im
Gasastreifen die in den arabischen
Fernsehsendern viel brutaler dargestellt
werden als das in unseren medie ist die
Stimmung gibt und zwar nicht nur im
Libanon sondern auch in der arabischen
Welt soass im Grunde genommen die
hisbolla quasi durch die Stimmung sich
gezwungen fühlt dort einzugreifen das
ist natürlich ein gefährliches Thema äh
und das gilt übrigens auch für die
anderen arabischen Führer wenn
die die Stimmung auf der arabischen
Straße oder in der Bevölkerung ist immer
schon anti-israelisch gewesen erinneren
sie sich an die Fußballweltmeisterschaft
als im Halbfinale
Marokko der marokkanische K Kapitän auf
einmal mit der palästinensischen Flagge
auf Spielfeld ging oder in in Qatar die
die die die qataris mit palestinänischen
Flaggen dort waren also die hisbolla hat
die die hamass hat ein geschafft so so
traurig das ist und so so zynisch das
ist dass sie die Palästina Frage jetzt
wieder auf die internationale
Tagesordnung gesetzt haben jetzt komme
ich zu meinem zweiten Punkt wir hatten
schon drüber gesprochen wenn der Krieg
im Gazastreifen vorbei ist und Israel
hoffentlich die Hamas besiegen kann dann
stellt sich sofort eine politische Frage
wir haben schon angesprochen wer
reagiert dann den den Gazastreifen ich
kann mir kaum vorstellen dass Israel das
will ich hatte ja schon nur kurz
geschildert wie wie dicht besiedelt das
ist das zu kontrollieren mit
militärischen Mitteln halte ich für
höchst problemematisch dann wenn man
dann stellt sich aber die nächste Frage
wer wird es sein und dann kommen wir
sofort in eine in eine politische Frage
wird es tatsächlich eine unomission
geben würden deutschen im Gasastreifen
mit dabei sein ich weiß nicht ob das
eine Politik ist
die die zum Erfolg führen wird also sie
sehen das sind eine ganze Menge Fragen
die auf uns zukommen und diese wollen
wir auch jetzt schon Bedenken und ich
glaube wir sollten gut daran tun schon
jetzt ein zwei Schritte Weiterdenken um
zu versuchen zumindestens dieses Problem
zuandberti hamass Rückhalt in der
Bevölkerung im gazasreifen sie hat ja
sämtliche wirtschaftlichen Machtmittel
in der Hand das Elend kann man ja sagen
im gazasreifen das ist ja schon fast
staatsron denn damit kann ich mit
eiserner Hand diese Bevölkerung so
leiden wie mir es passt ist dieser
Rückhalt da
oder bedeutet das jetzt vielleicht auch
dass
möglicherweise der ein oder andere sich
im gasersteifen überlegt dass das ja
eigentlich nur Elend also nicht Israel
sondern die die die Hamas Elend für das
Land bedeutet das machen ganz viele
Bewohner des Gazastreifens schon schon
sehr sehr lange man darf zunächst einmal
nicht vergessen dass das Votum von 2006
bei den Wahlen damals sehr knapp war und
das war vor allem ein
antikorruptionsvotum das war ein Votum
gegen die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde die ja nun bekannt
korrupt und fig und brutal ist bis heute
ist sie das also auch damals war die
Unterstützung für die Hamas schon nicht
so stark und die Hamas hat in den jetzt
mittlerweile 17 Jahren alles getan um
diese Unterstützung auch noch erodieren
zu lassen es hat in den letzten Monaten
eine ganze Reihe von Demonstrationen
gegeben da sind Leute auf die Straße
gegangen im Bewusstsein dass die Hamas
möglicherweise brutal zurückschlagen
wird was aus meiner Sicht ein Hinweis
darauf war wie groß die Unzufriedenheit
im Gazastreifen ist trotzdem ist die
Hamas nicht
al-Qaida oder eine andere kleine
isolierte Terrorgruppe sondern es ist
eine Massenbewegung sie ist aus der
Muslimbruderschaft
hervorgegangen und die
Muslimbruderschaft hat durchaus
Unterstützung im Gazastreifen wir müssen
damit rechnen dass einige hunderttaus
Menschen dort hinter der Hamas stehen
das ist sicherlich nicht die Hälfte der
Bevölkerung aber so einige hundertaus
werden das sein und das macht natürlich
einen solchen Krieg enorm schwierig das
macht vor allem aber dann anschließend
für jeden der dieses Gebiet
kontrollieren will der nicht die Hamas
ist enorm schwierig es wird dort auch
wenn dieser Krieg endet wenn er so endet
wie wir uns das wünschen nämlich mit
einem Sieg der Israelis und vielleicht
sogar wirklich mit einer Zerschlagung
der
Hamas dann wird er weitergeführt werden
und zwar gegen jede Kraft die versucht
dieses Gebiet unter Kontrolle zu aber
wenn ich noch mal zu hbolla was sagen
knte weil das ja der ganz entscheidende
Punkt ist gibt es einen Zweifrontenkrieg
oder bleibt es ruhig da weiß ich von den
Israelis die ganz ausdrücklich darauf
hingewiesen haben dass sie interne
Kanäle zur hiszbolla haben mit der sie
auch im Augenblick sprechen nach dem
Motto lass das bleiben und die
hiszbollah hat 2006 eine bittere Lektion
gelernt als die Israelis massiv die
Infrastruktur äh des Libanon in weiten
Teilen zerstört haben und die Israelis
haben den debiler immer klar gemacht
wenn ihr das noch mal macht dann wird
das sehr viel weitergehende Konsequenzen
haben bisher sind es nur Nadelstiche und
es fällt auch auf dass man in
Washington die iranische Gefahr
möglichst darunter spielt im
Augenblick im Weißen Haus ist gesagt
worden wie don't see a Smoking Gun also
wir sehen nicht ein unmittelbares
eingreifend des Iran und Washington hat
ein groß großes Interesse daran und
natürlich die westliche Welt insgesamt
dass es eben dass es eben nicht se ein
unmittelbaren Konfrontation mit dem Iran
kommt und das ist im Augenblick ist das
noch so ob sich das ändern wird durch
den Druck der Straße oder so oder durch
zu militärische Zufälle sonstige Dinge
das steht natürlich in den Sternen aber
im Augenblick fällt doch sehr auf dass
man versucht diese Konfrontation mit dem
Iran nicht so deutlich dies gesamten
Umfeld welche Rolle spielt da eigentlich
die Autonomiebehörde in ramala also Herr
Abbas hier sitzt der Experte aber es ist
ja schon alles gesagt worden das ist
eine hochkorrupte ärgerliche unfähige
Regierung spielt eigentlich keine Rolle
na ja sie spielt schon eine Rolle inem
Sie natürlich auf der einen Seite mit
Israel auf das engste kooperiert im
sicherheitsfeld seit vielen Jahren aus
Überlebensgründen wenn die Israelis und
und Abbas nicht zusammenarbeiten würden
wäre Abbas längst Geschichte das ist
ganz klar äh und trotzdem ist der Mann
extrem unpopulär in in der Bevölkerung
und deshalb baute sich in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten schon so etwas auf
wie eine fast eine dritte Intifada wo
die Israel ist ja auch massiv reagiert
haben in Genin vor allem und und dort
militärisch und blutig vorgegangen sind
also das ist auch eine Frage die wir
Deutsche uns mal stellen wollen wie
wollen wir eigentlich weiter mit diesem
korrupten Regime mit diesem Herrn Abbas
mit diesem unfähigen Führer der völlig
der keine Unterstützung mehr hat in
seiner eigenen Bevölkerung in Zukunft
weiter umgehen da wird ja fließt auch
sehr viel Geld hin von uns genau also
erstens haben wir heute noch nicht über
Qatar gesprochen denn die sind durchaus
sicherlich machtvoller äh was als als äh
äh die PA auch was das Thema der
Finanzierung der Hamas angeht aber auch
bis zur asylgebung ja von von
Führungskräften die in Qatar zu Besuch
sind oder zu Gast sind und ich hoffe
dass der Bundeskanzler der sich ja
morgen mit dem Emir von Qatar spreche
treffen wird wenn es denn schon sein
muss das sehr deutlich anspricht
übrigens auch was die Freilassung der
Geiseln angeht denn da haben die qataris
sicherlich unmittelbar ein haupfinanzi
der als Hauptfinanzier neben dem Iran
von von vielen vielen Milliarden was die
was die Hamas angeht auf jeden Fall
Einfluss und darüber wird der
Bundeskanzler sehr deutliche Worte
verlieren müssen das zweite
ist das Thema natürlich wie gehen wir
zukünftig mit den Zahlung um
ehrlicherweise ist das Thema schon lange
Thema es wollte nicht gehört werden dass
also eine Querfinanzierung
stattfindet auch nicht nur über die PR
oder unra sondern eben auch über die
Vorfeld Organisation zum Teil auch von
Hamas und heboll und deswegen ist
jedenfalls ein Moment ein gutes Moment
dass sowohl die Europäische Union aber
auch die Bundesregierung das Auswärtige
Amt und das
Entwicklungshilfeministerium nun sagen
wir frieren jedenfalls einen Teil der
Gelder ein ich aber gerne noch mal ank
weil es wichtig weil es wichtig ist Herr
Ree sie kennen sich im West jordanland
sehr gut aus in dieser Funktion als
Vertreter deutschlandsvertreter bei der
autonomehörde was würde das konkret
bedeuten wenn jetzt Gelder quasi
eingefroren werden würden wenn jetzt da
prtisch nichts mehr hinfließt man sagt
ja es gäbe den Unterschied zwischen der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit und der
humanitären Hilfe was würde das konkret
jetzt bedeuten ja das muss man sich
genau angucken aber Entwicklungshilfe
heißt ja häufig Wasserversorgung also
konkrete Projekte die dort sind die ja
häufig auch zusammen mit den Israelis
konzipiert werden den Israel nutzt ja
auch das Wasser aus dem westjollland
also das ist glaube ich eine eine Sache
die man relativ klar kontrollieren kann
und ich war ja vor 20 Jahren da aber
schon damals haben wir sehr genau
geguckt wo die Gelder hingehen
dann gibt's natürlich nicht
Regierungsorganisation da muss man sich
genau angucken welche sind gut und
welche sind sind nicht gut das ist nicht
nicht unproblematisch denn Israel hat ja
z.B auch einige
Nichtregierungsorganisationen wie alhak
eine Menschenrechtsorganisation Z
terroristischen Vereinigung erklärt also
man muss sich schon genau angucken
welche es nun ist und welche es nicht
ist wenn der Geld fließen sollte an
jemanden der tatsächlich Hamers nah ist
muss man das stoppen und auch unraah als
das palästinensische flüchtlingshilfwerk
ist hochkomplex an erstreifen haben die
13 000
Mitarbeiter betreiben Schulen
Krankenhäuser da kann natür der oput der
UN unter der aufut der UN und davon sind
jetzt schon getötet worden durch
israelische Bomben gen aber die die die
große Frage ist sind die alle die
versuchen Hamers rauszuhalten werden der
Hamers Anhänger drin sein wahrscheinlich
ja der gesunde Menschenverstand sagt
dann dass das wahrscheinlich so sein
wird Frage soll man damit die
Finanzierung beenden und damit diese die
Finanzierung der Schulen und der K geht
eine Konditionierung also es geht auch
um eine Konditionierung der der
Finanzierung das eine ist jetzt erstmal
stoppen um zu überprüfen wohin die
Mittel fließen denn eines kann nicht
sein dass auch mit deutschem Geld
palästinensischer Terror finanziert wird
die FR wie prüft man das das ist die
groß Frage aber es muss eben überhaupt
geprüft werden die Bereitschaft war zum
Teil weder bei der EU aber auch auf
Bundesebene nicht gegeben und deswegen
ist es gut dass es jetzt be passiert und
das eben sehr deutlich jetzt alle auch
formulieren alle demokratischen Parteien
zu sagen zukünftig müssen Zahlung
konditioniert werden und das heißt an
ein klares Bekenntnis nämlich des
abschwörens des Terrors und zum Existenz
des States Israel als dem jüdischen
Staat und das ist zwingend erforderlich
weil dem Grunde nach eines steht fest
und unra ist ein Beispiel dass
tatsächlich auch über Schulbücher auch
über Schulen zum Teil zum ter aufgerufen
worden ist und da dürfen wir nicht
wegschauen die Frage ist diese
flüchtlingsorganisation der UN besteht
ja immer wieder der Verdacht der jetzt
hier gerade auch schon angesprochen
worden wird das Geschäft der Hamas
besorgen ist kann man das so
sagen es ist äh in jedem Konflikt äh
dieser Art so äh wenn man also wenn ein
ein Gebiet von einer problematischen
Organisation beherrscht wird sein das
die Taliban sein das sein sei das die
Hamas oder auch eine andere Organisation
es fließen Hilfsgelder dann profitiert
die dort herrschende Organisation davon
und man muss das letzten Endes abwägen
inwieweit die humanitären Ziele dann
wichtiger sind als die Bekämpfung dieser
dieser dieser Gruppierung und das ist
immer das ist immer eine ganz schwierige
Sache ich würde im Moment darau dafür
plädieren ganz klar zu sagen wir haben
es hier mit einem Terrorakt zu tun mit
einem Terroranschlag oder einem
Terrorangriff einer terroristischen
Organisation und wir sollten klar machen
dass es nicht um die Palästinenser ist
dass es nicht um die die Bewohner des
Gazastreifens geht und wir sollten auch
die Israelis auffordern
immer wieder darauf zu achten dass sie
verhältnismäßig reagieren
es ist nicht die wichtigste Frage im
Moment
was die EU macht ähm es ist ohnehin
skandalös dass die Frage jetzt gestellt
werden muss wo denn dieses gan wo denn
dieses ganze Geld hingeht ganz wichtig
ist es im Moment darauf zu schauen wer
vielleicht von außen jetzt noch
Unterstützung in Richtung Hamas bringt
das ist einmal Iran natürlich aber auch
Katar und ihr Hinweis da war aus meiner
Sicht vollkommen richtig ich habe
Samstag Sonntag ganz viel Zeit damit
verbracht das arabische Programm der
Hamas der Hamas von
aljasira zu beobachten aber das war
schon das war schon fre freutscher
Versprecher das war wie ein propagandas
als sprachhor genutzt haben sie sie
würden es nicht glauben was für Bilder
am Samstag dort zu sehen waren Ismail
han ohne Kommentar durfte eine also der
politbürochef der Hamas in Doha durfte
eine halbe Stunde reden
unkommentiert und danach in den
Berichten wurde dann das Vokabular der
Hamas auch noch weitergenutzt also vom
Widerstand beispielsweise oder auch oder
auch die Bezeichnung Kriegsgefangene für
die für die Geis diese Dinge und das
sollte der Bundeskanzler in jedem Fall
anspre also eine hoch problematische
hochbresante Situation deren Ausgang
unklar ist ich bedanke mich bei Gitter
konnemann bei Andreas reinike bei
Steinberg und bei wner Sonne wenn ich
darf ein einziges PS anfügen möchte wir
müssen darauf achten dass die Ukraine
nicht der kol Schaden des Israel
Konfliktes wird und dass wir weiterhin
auch dorthin gucken denn da steht auch
für uns weiterhin viel auf dem
Spiel gut das die phönixrunde Liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer morgen in
der phönixrunde mit Anke Plettner
Solidarität mit Israel was ist zu tun
jetzt kommt Phönix der Tag mit Florian
Bauer darin unter anderem die Vorschläge
der Ampel zur asylreform bleiben Sie bei
[Musik]
uns Phönix der
Tag ein turbulenter Tag heute in der
deutschen und in der Weltpolitik gut
dass Sie hier sind bei uns herzlich
Willkommen zu Phönix der Tag und das
sind unsere
Themen mehr in Israel und in den
Palästinensergebieten